um well just that first lock down and
having the kind of um
the first few days of it or the first
few weeks of it and being kind of
rudderless and trying to work out where
you're i mean how to deal with it
basically
and i suppose as a kind of creative
person or a writer you sort of have that
added
thing of trying to work out what you
should be doing what you should be
writing
and i had other projects that i was
trying to do and difficult to
concentrate on
then in the evenings i'd write stuff
about lockdown and that was kind of
yeah obviously much more so therapeutic
and
enjoyable so i kind of cleared the decks
and tried to get rid of everything else
and then just um went to be fair quite
deep state and just
uh wrote about the lockdown from inside
the lockdown
and when you you got to to the end of
where you thought you had stuff for a
book and and went back
and looked at what you'd written were
you surprised at the evolution of your
emotions over that time
yeah definitely i mean i was writing
poems so that
the first kind of um part of writing the
book was just
sort of documenting stuff that has had
happened during the
during the lockdown and doing the
pandemic but then i started writing
conversations and kind of
jotting down the conversations i was
having which is the other strand of the
book
and so yeah there's something about when
i've reread the book now with a bit of
space behind it
there's something about the poems just
kind of um you know setting out what
happened in the lockdown and what was
going on in march april may june of last
year
and then meanwhile yes a deterioration
of my own well-being i mean my sort of
personal lockdown was i mean everyone
has their kind of story or where they
fit in
mine was living on my own in a flat in
lockdown so it was kind of
i mean i was sort of you know ramping it
up a bit but yeah a guy kind of
trying to stay sane during lockdown was
is kind of the way that the story goes
and yeah certainly in the story i
completely fall apart i mean in real
life
ironically i didn't fall apart because i
was writing the story i think that was
what was happening
but i mean with a bit more distance i'll
probably work out slightly more
what was going on what happens when the
lockdown ends i mean
are you concerned at all that the
creativity that that you you focused on
during this time you'll
you lose your muse almost
yeah yeah totally it was is a very kind
of
i mean once you embrace it and decide
that that's what you're going to do
that you decide to forget about the fact
that everyone will be writing about
lockdown once you decide yeah i'm going
to be one of those people
then it just it takes out an enormous
part of the writing process where
you're not trying to think of ideas and
you're not trying to
um you know come up with any spark of
you know originality
or start to write something it's just
all there and it's all around you so if
you decide to sort of swim
inside it all then yeah it's very useful
but i mean
i thought that at the end of the
lockdown and uh weirdly um there's
another lockdown
they keep on coming do you think there's
gonna be
that's not what i don't know so as i was
gonna say i don't want more and more
locked down so i can write more i would
like an end to it
but yeah there is a sort of silver
lining where i kind of think okay i'm
back in again i'll keep on writing
but are you worried that there'll be a
market for this book
because you know everyone's well most
people it seems have really hated
lockdown
does anybody want to be reminded of this
year you know is everyone gonna go
i mean i think lockdown itself is a
great time to enjoy poetry because you
might have a bit of extra time
to sit and go through books you haven't
had a chance to go through but do you
think in five years time we're going to
be saying
let's revisit that lockdown year
no i don't think so
so you're not you're not planning on
paying off the mortgage with it
no there's no market for it no i don't
know weirdly it's out now so people have
bought it and
the main kind of um people would be
really nice about it and obviously
because
we're in an age where they can sort of
contact you on
social media or you know you see it
going up on on social media
and i think people's reaction has been
really nice that they're kind of
um they do kind of feel i i i i totally
agree i wouldn't
i'd hate to watch anything about
lockdown or reading about lockdown at
this point but people have sort of
um i don't know it doesn't sort of
obviously it doesn't glamorize it but i
think people
kind of can empathize with this is just
one person's
route through it and i don't think
there's any sort of particular nostalgia
about lockdown one
but i think there is something um that's
i mean it's so universal
everyone went through it and i mean the
fact it probably helps that the book is
comedy it's it's not trying to make any
great
political or social points it's just
kind of a
300 pages of sort of madness and i feel
like
it because it doesn't really have it too
much pretension about it
maybe it's slightly more palatable
well let's give you a taste of what's in
the book um
you're going to read for us one of the
poems pile them high
oh yeah so this is in the period where
people were sort of
furious about groups meeting in parks
and you know all of that so
the parks got full the government waved
through a new policy
stacking now groups were allowed to
assemble on top of one another
up to five groups of ten could stack
like this
park wardens enforce a strict two meter
gap in between the stacks
joggers weave between the stacks and
sometimes clambered over them
they'd rest on top of the revelers and
drink cider before scrambling back down
and jogging on once more
snorting panting slaloming between these
government-sanctioned piles of
irrepressible humanity
you know it's that kind of thing i love
it and very briefly before we go
in the book you also write a love poem
to a girl
and you say that you can do things in
books that you can't do in real life ah
you might put your head in your hands
um have you had the courage to do it in
real life have you written to her
come on you know you've got to read the
book
or the follow-ups um yeah
uh that's it's a sort of um the whole
book is kind of a mixture of
um autobiography and complete fiction
so um i mean you you read the book you
tell me where that fits in
i don't know okay well can i just say
quickly before before
i want to just mention my designer
because the book is a real collaboration
between me and
my designer emily juniper and uh that's
all of the feedback has been
very little about what's been inside it
but just saying it looks beautiful which
i agree with but it's obviously quite
it's beautifully set out well tim it's
been lovely to talk to you
best of luck with your love life good to
see you